M Martine est là et les autres
auaussi. Bonsoir.
JeJe vous fais ce qui n'est pas
avavec nous de réécouter le résé
dede la coronaire ce matin qui n
dedeux mots a dit que le racisme
jojoue un rôle important dans la
momort de Joyce Echaquan.
EtEt de la réponse synthèse de
MoMonsieur Legault, qui sans
adadopter le racisme systémique
ququ'il faut qu'on lutte contree
raracisme évidemment.
MeMe GÉHANE KAMEL, coroner
- - Est-ce qu'en 2021 au Québec,
onon peut laisser quelqu'un mour
paparce que cette personne est
coconsidérée... au même niveau
ququ'un animal? Utilisez le mot
vovous voudrez, si c'est pour
nonous rapprocher, faisons-le,
n'n'hésitons pas à faire
leles premiers pas qu'on appelle
ininstitutionnel qu'on l'appella
cocomme on voudra, moi,
jeje ne voudrais pas tant qu'on
s's'accroche sur les mots que
lele fait de rater un rendez-vos
imimportant et historique.
- - Quand on parle de comment
çaça fonctionnait dans les
pepensionnats autochtones, c'étt
dudu racisme systémique qui état
totoléré. J'ai été ministre
dede l'Éducation, j'ai été
miministre de la santé, je n'ai
jajamais vu un système qui part
d'd'un haut puis qui demande
àà tous les employés de faire
dede la discrimination.
- - Ce serait quoi la conséquene
sisi le gouvernement disait : on
rereconnaît le racisme systémiq.
- - Pourquoi je reconnaîtrais
unune situation qui n'est pas,
seselon moi, exacte?
JeJe ne comprends pas.
- - Monsieur Legault et on n'a s
totout ressassé.
IlIl a fait ses définitions. Ila
paparlé du petit Robert elle a t
quque si ça ne vient pas d'en
hahaut, si un ministre ou une
auautorité politique ou
adadministrative qui ne commande
papas, comme c'était le cas pour
leles pensionnats, il dit que
c'c'est vrai à cette racisme
sysystémique. Aujourd'hui,
pepersonne commande au, ce n'est
papas du racisme systémique à sn
avavis. Je pense qu'on est alléu
bobout de la logique. C'est
teterminé.
- - C'est terminé. Il ne le
rereconnaîtra pas. Essentiellemt
paparce que je ne veux pas savor
jujusqu'où ça va aller. Est-ce e
çaça va invalider certaines loi,
IlIl a donné sa propre définitin
ququi est très simple, beaucoup
plplus simple de la commission s
drdroits de la personne.
CeCe qui est particulier, c'est
quque le débat est de moins en .
MMême sur le terrain politique,
ilil est très polarisé. Elle
didivise. Il y a les bons et les
méméchants. Cuex qui sont pour t
cocontre. Pour les autochtones,
soson incarnation de ce qui leur
ararrive. C'est important. En
paparallèle, je dirais que les
didiscussions avancent quand mêe
avavec les personnes autochtone.
J'J'écoutaisis quand même à Ghin
PiPicard, est-ce que on va aller
plplus loin? C'est sûr que les
auautochtones au Québec ont
tetellement été victime de racie
quque pour eux, cette
rereconnaissance, c'est devenu e
papas à franchir pour aller plus
loloin.
- - C'est la question que j'alls
poposer. Manifestement, Monsieur
LeLegault n'avait pas reconnaît,
ilil a des problèmes avec ce
coconcept. Mais cela peut devenr
politiquement un problème. Je
papars pas au salon bleu, mais
faface aux autochtones. S'ils se
memettent à ne plus vouloir parr
ouou à mettre du sable dans
l'l'engrenagage, cela n'aidera .
- - Évidemment ça n'aide pas. Je
nene sais pas jusqu'où les menas
quque Monsieur Picard a fait avs
alallé. Il y a quand même des
didiscussions qui sont utiles
ququand on parle de la protectin
dede la jeunesse, les discussios
ququi ont eu lieu sur la sécurié
pupublique. Je pense qu'on peut
fafaire un bout de chemin sur cs
ququestions sans nécessairement
rerevenir toujours à la question
dudu racisme systémique. Elle va
dedemeurer dans le paysage. Il y
a a aucun problème. Monsieur
LeLegault, j'ai trouvé un petit
bobout, avançant c'est-à-dire ds
inindividus est maintenant une
papart de groupe. On grossit un
pepeu l'affaire. Écoutez, persoe
ququi dit qu'il y a des dirigeas
àà un système de santé ou dans
d'd'autres systèmes qui donnentn
momot d'ordre en disant : les
auautochtones, c'est le service
miminimum. Ce n'est pas ça du
totout. La coroner a parfaitemet
exexpliqué ce qui s'était passéà
JoJoliette. Il y a des biens et
dedes préjugés dans les systèmes
ququi fêtent en sorte que les gs
rereçoivent un moins bon
trtraitement et il y a des gens
ququi voient cela et qui ne dist
ririen. Ça le problème. Si
MoMonsieur Legault n'avait pas
l'l'avoir, ça ne veut pas dire e
çaça n'existe pas.
- - Christian, quand la coroner
paparle justement de
l'l'accumulation des billets,
prprenant le cas de Joyce
EcEchaquan, en disant qu'il y a
dedes personnes à l'accueil, les
ininfirmières, médecins, les
sese sont accumulés. Ça ressembe
àà un système le fait... est-ce
ququ'on peut encore parler
d'd'accumulation de gestes
inindividuels?
- - Je trouve que le rapport dea
cocoroner comporte deux parties.
UnUne partie où elle dit que c't
dudu racisme ce qui est arrivé.t
elelle donne des démonstrationse
cecela. L'autre partie, elle
emembarque dans le débat sur le
raracisme systémique. Je trouve
cocompte la première partie fais
l'l'unanimité. On parle beaucoup
dede racisme il y en a. On ne pt
papas dire consommer la tête das
lele sable. Dans la deuxième
papartie, je trouve que Monsieur
LeLegault a été entre la coroner
elelle a dit qu'il y a de visio.
ElElle a sa vision et moi j'ai a
mimienne. J'ai tendance à virer
plplus que la coroner récentes e
soson mandat. Je crois à beauco.
CeCe n'est pas le rôle du coron.
LeLe cornard regarde les faits t
reregarde ce qui s'est passé. Ee
s's'est lancée dans un débat
popolitique et ce n'était pas sn
rrôle du tout. Monsieur Legault,
unune semaine peut faire la
didifférence. Monsieur Legault,
soson ton était bon. Il avait
l'l'air de bonne humeur. Ça fait
dudu bien dans ce dossier qui pt
tetellement être pourri. Il
exexplique de façon très simple.
ElElle expliquait pourquoi le
raracisme systémique n'avait pas
sasa place. C'est un débat sans
fifin. Mon opinion, si ça vous
inintéresse, plus ça va et pluse
raracisme systémique un aspect
mymystificateur. Il y a de
l'l'hypocrisie. À Ottawa, on est
llà-dedans depuis 20 ans. Qu'es-
cece que ça a changé dans les
auautochtones? Il y a des résers
ququi n'ont pas d'eau. Je croyas
unune seconde que la racisme
sysystémique va améliorer la
cocondition concret des
auautochtones, je serai pour ça.
CoComment serait-il que personne
nene parle jamais de la loi sur
leles Indiens? Il y a un
raracisme...
- onon n'en a parlé.
- - Quand est-ce que qu'on va la
chchanger ou la modifier?
- - On a parlé de cela pendant e
cacampagne qui n'était pas si
lolointaine. Je veux revenir sur
MoMonsieur Legault.
JeJe vais vous faire écouter où
elelle dit lui-même : j'étais en
mamaudi hier. J'avais vu cette
vividéo du député et j'aurais ps
ddû. Elle donne raison à tous ls
ananalystes de toutes les coules
popolitiques, de tous les horizs
ququ'il a passé une mauvaise
mamanière. On l'écoute.
- - Ça été plus fort que moi.
JeJe n'aurais pas dû faire ça
cocompte tenu que ça faisait
unun an, le décès
dede Joyce Echaquan. Même
sisi j'étais choqué de ce
quque Greg Kelly avait dit.
C'C'est totalement inacceptable,
j'j'aurais dû garder ça pour mo.
- - Martine, c'est un vrai mea
cuculpa. Lancé vrai.
IlIl dit que je n'aurais pas dûe
lalaisser aller surtout pas cete
jojournée.
- - Il y a deux choses à dire l-
dedessus. D'abord, la ministre
reresponsable des affaires
auautochtones dans le corridor e
l'l'Assemblée nationale tout à
l'l'heure disait que ça a eu des
rérépercussions sur le terrain.
LaLa déclaration et son attitude
onont eu un impact sur les
coconversations qu'ils ont avec
leles autochtones. Ça a mal été.
MoMonsieur Legault devait rétabr
çaça. La deuxième chose, c'est e
reremarquer qu'il a à nouveau ft
papart du fameux vidéo de Kelly
ququi mélange la loi sur la
lalaïcité, le projet de loi sura
lalangue et le décès de Madame
JoJoyce Echaquan. Je pense que
cecela incarna c'est bien la
crcrainte quand Monsieur Legault
dede reconnaître le racisme
sysystémique, c'est-à-dire que e
sosont des lois importantes au
QuQuébec et peut-être que
cecertaines personnes pourraient
fafaire des liens, il y en a qui
lele font déjà, de liens avec le
raracisme. Est-ce que c'est lois
popourraient éventuellement être
cocontesté?
- - C'est l'argument qu'on ente.
SiSi elle reconnaît pour les
auautochtones, il va y avoir une
pepente glissante. Ce n'est pas
clclair dans mon esprit les étas
dede cette pente.
- - D'une part, si Monsieur
LeLegault le reconnaît dans le s
dedes autochtones, je vois mal
popourquoi il reconnaîtra pendat
lala minorité visible. Elles sot
seses victimes de racisme
sysystémique en l'occurrence.
MaMais Monsieur Legault, il s'et
exexcusé aujourd'hui. J'ai
l'l'impression qu'il s'excusait
plplutôt du moment où il avait t
cece qu'il a dit. Ce n'était pas
lele moment de parler de ça queu
fofond de la question. Elle a
paparlé du jour férié et il a dt
quque non, ça va nuire à la
prproductivité, c'était peut-ête
papas le moment de dire ça. Elle
pepense ça quand même. Ça souvet
ouou à le problème de Monsieur
LeLegault. Il y a des choses qui
nene se ramènent pas simplementà
l'l'économie. S'en était une.
IlIl est commis une gaffe, il sn
esest rendu compte. Je ne pense
papas qu'elle s'est excusée du
fofond de ce qu'il avait dit. Il
s's'est excusé du moment...
- - absence de contexte.
- - J'ai noté qu'il sait pas
vrvraiment excuser. Il a exprimé
seses regrets. Ce n'est pas la
mmême chose. C'est vrai, mais ça
raraison. Ce n'était pas des
reregrets sur le fond. C'était r
lele contexte elle a bien fait e
lele faire. Tout le monde l'a né
lala semaine passée, ce n'était
papas des réactions à la hauteur
dede premier ministre. Les taux
d'd'approbation de Monsieur
LeLegault sont tellement énormes
ququ'il faut qu'il fasse
atattention. Par rapport aux
coconséquences, c'est un débat
sasans fin, la reconnaissance de
raracisme systémique, il faudrat
qu'il y ait un début d'autre
chchose et demande des excuses,
inindemnisation, on entrerait ds
unun tout nouveau chapitre. Son
ététat plus soulevé quelque choe
ququi réglerait le problème et s
auautochtones seraient contents.
IlIl y a beaucoup de Québécois i
nene sont pas intéressants ça ps
- - est-ce que pour apaiser les
chchefs des premières nations, n
nene pourrait pas dire que eux
ututilise les termes génériques
cocontre, moi je ne l'utilise ps
paparce que ça renvoie une
dédéfinition qui n'est pas la
mimienne. Elle ne va même pas
jujusqu'à dire ça.
IlIl y a une logique de où on se
rerencontre jamais en ce moment.
- - Qu'est-ce que ça change
coconditions de vie? Il ne faut
papas idéaliser non plus les chs
auautochtones. Elle a eu dans un
scscandale qui les ont visé.
CeCe sont des élèves contre
d'd'autres élèves. Je m'intérese
auau monde concret. Ce que j'aie
dede François Legault, ce que
l'l'approche concrète. Ian
LaLafrenière, son bilan est
inintéressant. C'est étonnant
l'l'obsession sur le concept.
L'L'importance de racisme concr.
CoComment ça se fait que dans la
réréserve n'a pas le mot eau
popotable?
- - Très bien.
- - Le problème c'est que quandn
ididentifie pas le problème, on
ririsque de passer à côté de la
sosolution. Si Monsieur Legault
cocontinue à considérer ça comme
unun problème individuel que cea
vava prendre des thérapies
inindividuelles pour régler le
prproblème de toute évidence.
- - Il ne dit pas que c'est
inindividuelles et je pense...
- - non ce n'est pas ça. Le
raracisme systémique sans un coe
woword des États-Unis.
CeCela vient du Canada anglais.
- - La propriété n'est pas
amaméricaine.
- - On a importé des Américains.
- - Cinq débats sans fin.
IlIl ne changera pas d'idée,
MoMonsieur Legault après la
cocoronaire. Poursuivons.
OnOn a parlé des sondages. Écouz
cece qui suit. Monsieur Legault
avavait déjà dit : je vais me
rereprésenter mais au milieu de
l'l'autre mandat, mon âge fera e
pepeut-être j'irai faire autre
chchose. Or, non seulement elle
didit qu'elle va finir le deuxie
mamandat s'il est élu, mais
popourquoi pas un troisième?
- - Puis quand on dit 10 ans,
bibien évidemment, à l'époque,
jeje pensais que je serais tout
dede suite premier ministre
pupuis je ferais 10 ans
cocomme premier ministre, là.
PoPour l'instant, j'en ai juste
trtrois de faites. Vous pouvez
VoVous pouvez vous imaginer,
ququand je me suis présenté
enen 2018, ce n'était pas
popour gérer la pandémie,
dodonc j'ai d'autres objectifs.
- - Elle dit que la pandémie a
chchangé sa vision. Il a des
chchoses à changer. J'ai été
dédétourné.
- - J'ai entendu en fin de semae
ququ'elle 60, ça ne vaut 40.
7070 pourraient être le nouveau
5050. Monsieur Legault est dans
unune situation où il s'est renu
cocompte que ça laissait entende
ququ'il était pour partir, il
dedevenait automatiquement un
cacanard boiteux. C'est ingérab.
IlIl va être obligé de gérer son
cacaucus, son conseil des
miministres, parce qu'il y a des
gegens qui vont commencer en
cacatimini à s'organiser. C'est
imimpossible pour lui de laisser
enentendre qu'il pourrait partir
ququelque part dans le prochain
mamandat. Évidemment, les choses
pepeuvent changer dans la vie. l
a a été assez clair là-dessus et
gagarder les deux mains sur le
vovolant jusqu'à la fin.
- - Il reste les objectifs de
hahausser le niveau de vie du
QuQuébec autant que celui de
l'l'Ontario. Il revient à ses
fofondamentaux à lui. Michel
- - il avait laissé entendre ily
a a deux ans qui ne finiraient s
lele premier mandat. Personne na
lele goût de lire premier minise
ququi va lâcher le travail un an
ouou deux après. Pour ça, il a
cocorrigé le tir de ce moment. e
pepense que oui, Monsieur Legaut
a a perdu a été occupé à autre
chchose pendant la grosse moitié
dede son mandat. Et comme tous s
prpremiers ministres, il veut
lalaisser une marque et je pense
quque l'économie, le système de
sasanté, éducation, ce sont des
chchoses qui le tiennent vraimet
àà coeur. Ça bien avant la
papandémie. L'économie québécoie
sese redressait un rythme vraimt
inintéressant. Et je pense qu'ee
veveut poursuivre sur cette
lalancée. Elle corrigeait une
imimpressision qui aurait pu ête
dodommageable, mais il y a un fd
dede vrai là-dedans.
- - C'est clair.
- - On n'en aura jusqu'à 2030 ac
FrFrançois Legault. Plus
sésérieusement, je trouvais ça
cacandide de la façon dont il ea
paparlé. Il établit aujourd'huh.
CeCela contrastait avec la semae
papassée. J'avais l'impression e
prpremier ministre du Québec qua
gégéré la pandémie comme ça sert
àà moitié mort, sur le bord de a
dédépression. Ce n'est pas du tt
çaça que l'envoyé de message
auaujourd'hui. Il était de bonne
huhumeur. Il n'était pas fatigu.
IlIl faut continuer. Il faut vor
ququ'il se régénère. Ça m'a
frfrappé.
- - Il y a des choses qu'il veut
fafaire et qu'il y a eu une
paparenthèse obligatoire, obligé
ququi a fait qu'il a remis à pls
tatard plein de projets. On ver.
QuQu'est-ce qu'on suit Martine?
ElElle n'a pas confirmé que ça a
êêtre prolongé mais ça va l'êtr.
- - C'est le plan que jeudi il
feferme la session parlementaire
popour faire un discours
d'd'ouverturure au retour de lae
paparlementaire, ce qui veut die
mamardi le 19 octobre.
- - C'est noté. On ser